hey boy you over here getting chopped up
[Music]
boy
God
God you said only God is the truth
correct yes I said what I said I said
that go I asked you first I asked you
first that is God the truth and you said
what please stop wasting my time you
agree that only God you you you yourself
said it that only God is the only God
Only God is the truth only God is the
truth go ahead Ahad now let's let's get
to the point now so if only God is the
truth if Jesus says that he's the truth
then he's claiming to be God right no he
is not Avery that's the whole point this
is like I was saying
before the first thing we got to
establish is the context of what Jesus
was speaking
that's the first thing we got to
establish what context was he speaking
in and the second thing we got to
establish is is is the Bible the word of
God
why we don't have to establish if the
Bible is the word of God or not or the
context If Only God is the truth if only
God is the truth and Jesus claims to be
the truth then he claims to be God it's
a simple syllogism premise one no
problem no problem no problem okay
follow okay premise the claim the claim
here okay only God is the truth CLA here
premise one only God is the truth
premise two I'm with you I'm says he's
the truth conclusion I'm with I'm with
you okay okay Avery I'm with you only
only God is the truth okay only God is
truth I'm with you okay all right what's
what's the rest of the verse no one
comes to the father except through me
so is he talking about himself or is he
talking about something else is he
talking about his own Divinity yeah he's
talking about both you're saying Avery
that this verse here I am the way the
truth and the life no one gets to the
father he had the life that's what I
said no one comes to the father except
through me this means that he's Divine
that's what you're saying yes
yes okay by the context of that very
same verse that you quoted it's not
proof that he's Divine and it's very
clear from the context because if you
are coming to the father you're not
going to you're not at this point you're
Jesus is directing you to somebody else
correct yes or no it's both you got to
come to Jesus to get to the father and
the father brings you to Jesus it's both
okay no no worries when Jesus was asked
how to pray what did he say I'll show
you I'll show you when Jesus when Jesus
is asked how to pray matter of fact
we'll stay in John 14 to explain this
when Jesus is ask go ahead go ahead yeah
I got you brother this's what he says
verse 13 and 14 whatever you ask in my
name this I will do same chapter by the
way that he says he's the
truth that the father may be glorified
in the son if you ask me anything in my
name I will do it according to Jesus who
are we praying to and who answers our
prayers Avery again you know well I'm
not asking about this you know very well
Avery I'm not asking about
this go ahead try again
Avery go ahead you're gonna get rich
tonight don't worry you're gonna get
rich go
ahead
boy boy you boy you boy hey hey boy you
over here getting chopped up boy
you getting chopped up come on bring me
back on bring me back on chop me up chop
me up go ahead okay okay go ahead you
know what I'm asking go ahead Avery
Jesus answered your question according
to the
verse I asked you again when Jesus was
asked okay you know what let me get the
verse let me get the verse gonna be
running around all day one second one
second let me get you post it you post
it let me get the verse you
posted one second ay please away from
I'm not running from from anything Avery
I'm here right okay good you're about to
get very very rich don't worry you're
gonna make money tonight you're gonna
make money tonight Jesus say who does
Jesus say that we pray to and who
answers our prayers according to what
Jesus just said here on the screen yeah
one one moment fav one minut ay doesn't
take a moment just answer it one minute
Avery one minute whatever you let us be
clear let's be crystal clear clear first
okay I don't I don't believe in the
gospel the Gospel of John okay but you
just asked me believe in the Gospel of
John so it's not it's not a Criterion
for me right but I'm answering questions
from the Gospel of John as a as a what
call a courtesy to you because we're
having this conversation okay but you
you asked me how does you asked me how
did Jesus teach you to pray I'm showing
you so I know this isn't your Authority
but you can at least be honest with the
text right you don't have to reject the
text just because you're a Muslim I know
you don't believe this no I can reject
the text I can I can reject the text
outright I don't believe in that but
what I'm saying what I'm saying is you
can't you can't don't
believe no you're Miss you're no I asked
you when Jesus was asked how to pray
when Jesus is asked what does he say
right here what do he I'm asking you
when he and who answers our prayers
According To
Jesus one second let me get the please
answer it's right here one second let me
get the verse Avery you know what I'm
asking anyways you know here from
whatever you ask in my name this I will
do that the father may be glorified in
the son if you ask me in anything in my
name I will do it who does Jesus tell us
to pray
to again for me John is not an authority
but the question was again when he was
asked directly Rabbi how do we pray what
did he say see you can't even answer the
question yeah I can't because that's not
Authority to
me and this and you know answer to the
question you can just you can just go
you can just go to the to the to what
I'm asking you can if you want just just
just answer this at least according to
this text Jesus says that we can pray
even the Book of John for me is not an
authority I'm asking you a different
question I'm not asking you about the
Book of John for me for me you know what
I feel about the I think you know what I
feel about the Book of John anyways I
say what the scholar say about the Book
of John wait so do you believe do you
believe in the Book of
Matthew I don't believe
any of those gospels so why are you
neglecting John if I bring up Matthew
you reject that too why are you trying
to go to Matthew or Mark or Luke or John
I'm sorry Matthew Mark I'm not trying to
go to Matthew Mark or Luke or John I
asked you when Jesus was asked how to
pray what did he
say and you know the answer that's why
that's why you're smirking and giggling
and laughing you know what he said I'm
telling you what he said it's very easy
every Christian in every Christian in
the audience knows what he said to you
said only God is the truth and we see
here in John 14:6 Jesus claims to be the
truth can you break down to me how that
doesn't mean that Jesus is claiming to
be God how can Jesus claim to be the
truth which only God is and not be
claiming to be God please break that
down he's talking about his message and
it's and the context is in the very same
verse it's in the same verse I am the
truth I'm the way the truth to and the
light no one comes to the father except
through me he's either is he directing
you to himself or is he directing you to
the father who's he directing directing
the people to himself how do you get to
the
father yeah through G through Jesus so
who is he directing you just like every
other Prophet every other messenger okay
can you show me where any other Prophet
or any other messenger said in order to
get to God you have to go through me
show me that show me where Moses Adam
Abraham anyone made that statement
Muhammad show me where they made the
statement the prophet peace be upon him
he said and as a matter of fact in the
Quran it says that uh he says tell them
if you love Allah to follow me and then
Allah will love you and he will uh
forgive you your sins anyways the whole
point is that if you love Allah what is
the pro what is Allah ordering the
prophet Muhammad to follow who follow
him so you quoted a verse that says that
if you if you love Allah then follow me
then so after after you follow me then
Allah will love you and forgive your
sins is that correct that's correct so
the Forgiveness of of your sins and the
love of Allah is contingent upon your
your following
Muhammad yes of
course and you mean to tell me that
that's not Sher
[Music]
oh my God logic